Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wo sind wir hier?
Wir sind im Saalbau in Bornheim in Frankfurt.
Hinter uns sind wir.
Und gleich beginnt die große Live-Show. Ich habe schon gehört, du hast dir Sommerinterviews angesehen.
Alle.
Aber ein bisschen anders, nämlich wie junge Menschen das machen als Twitch-Stream.
Die Tagesschau macht ein Tagesschau-together-Format. Dort wird das 30 Minuten Sommerinterview in drei Stunden gestreamt. Das heißt, da ist sehr viel Zeit Blödsinn zu labern. Und junge Leute zu indoktrinieren, falls du es noch nicht wusstest. Von Birgensdörr ganz böse, schlagähnig, wurde aussortiert, historisch überholt und so. Wir überprüfen nachher die Argumentation.
Ich habe Clips dabei, vor allem von Taylor Lawrence. Sie setzt sich ja sehr stark für Free Speech ein. Und ich muss auch sagen, je mehr ich über all das nachdenke, desto mehr komme ich auch zu dem Schluss, ich bin für absolute Free Speech. Jetzt sind wir ja bekanntlich welche, die auch immer gewarnt haben, vor Folgen soziale Medien und so weiter. Stichwort Manfred Spitzer oder manche Thesen von Jonathan Hyde fanden wir auch gar nicht so schlecht. Ich bin gespannt, wie du dich gleich dazu in Stellung bringen wirst. Ich habe den Eindruck, du wirst widersprechen. Aber ich glaube, es geht nicht ohne Free Speech. Und wir dürfen, um das Bild einmal zu gebrauchen, das Kind nicht mit dem Bade ausgießen. Und das geschieht gerade.